if it's Big Brother
we're gonna fix it
toughest fixes
I'm about to climb into the belly of
that beast
she is radiance of the Seas where we're
going to install a brand new less costly
power plant that will save will
Caribbean Millions hands inside the ride
we're both on the way we're gonna try to
move up alongside for our gear in and
jump on board hello folks
day one some 300 workers swarm on to the
radiance of the Seas bill work around
the clock in 12-hour shifts for the next
20 days and some of the most dangerous
conditions imaginable
most of them head to space it's three
levels below the ship's waterline to
clear out room for the new power plant
this thing is the size of a city bus
it's really two machines in one one side
is like your car motor on steroids
a giant 15,000 horsepower engine which
drives the other side an electric
generator together they crank out nearly
12,000 kilowatts of electricity that's
enough to light the small city
that engine has to fit into a space now
crisscross bye vital pipes and cables
these men have to cut reroute and weld
up nearly every one of them it is nasty
sweaty hot conditions down here some of
these are water pipes some of them sewer
pipes some of them electrical there's
over two miles of piping will be
rerouted around this room that's why you
can't do this overnight it'll take days
of 24 hour shifts to get this done but
this crews next assignment is even
tougher they have to lift the engine
three meters into the air so that they
can slide it into the hole on the ship's
hull meanwhile in the engine room men
are racing to remove the last lap of
hull they need it off today where they
fall behind
this ship sails in less than two weeks
then there's an unexpected setback it's
a pipe leak someone somewhere has
accidentally opened about releasing
wastewater the waters not just dangerous
to work in it stinks so we've run for
the hole basically I'm gonna stay here
by the open hole try and get a breath
it's well into the next day before the
crew finishes the bridge we'll use to
move our huge engine into the ship now
we need muscle and lots of it
fortunately we have the modern beasts of
burden to do the pulling for us
mechanical hoists
this is what's going to supply the power
to drag the engine into the ship
pneumatic chain hoist by shrinking the
chain they're gonna pull the engine all
the way inside we've attached a hoist to
each side of the engines base those two
hoists working in unison slowly drag it
forward even so it's gonna be like
hauling a house up a driveway and into a
garage that's barely big enough for it
to fit in and we'll need more than just
muscle will also need plenty of grease
it is crunch time this is where the
engine could get really stuck
it slides into the ship with just
centimetres to spare an hour later it's
within a meter of the back wall this
motors almost all the way in with one
more stroke to do I think I'm gonna get
out of the way we've been at this for 24
hours solid now I'm beat up from the
feet up but we have got it within three
feet of hitting the back wall talk about
a fight it was supposed to take only
half a day but after to noise and
sixteen hours of untold toil sweat and
heartbreak this cruise ships massive new
power plant is finally in place the
final days are a frenzy of activity
the diesel generator has it's blue cover
off and it's just resting there in its
new home beneath the waterline on the
starboard side of the ship all the work
has been racing overnight the last 24
hours to try to get the floor welded
into place and move on to the next step
which can rebuild the wound in the side
of the ship the home Alka listens thanks
to a brand new paint job and inside the
workers have cleaned out most of the
shipyard dust yeah all of the inspection
teams and tests are being completed and
this is the fastest you've ever done
this job isn't it is there yeah at one
point we fell almost a full day behind
but in the end the crew of the grand
bahama shipyards beats the deadline and
they set a new record for this cruise
ship fix